[MUSIC PLAYING]
YAFIT BECHER: Wow.
It's hard to believe
it's been only a year
since we launched the
App Bundle here at I/O.
And what an incredible
year it was.
I'm Yafit Becher, a product
manager with the Play London
team.
MARTIN CHURCHILL: And I'm
Martin, a software engineer
on Google Play in London.
So today, we're going
to talk about what's new
this year in the world
of Android app bundles.
So many developers have
bought into our vision
to optimize tailored delivery,
and have already migrated
to the App Bundle.
This includes some of
the most popular apps
on Play seeing incredible
size savings, that
range from around 10%
to 60% versus delivering
a universal APK.
We really couldn't
have hoped for a better
acceptance of the App Bundle
among the developer community.
And Google Apps are
migrating, as well.
So this includes apps such
as Photos, Maps, and YouTube,
which have dramatically
reduced their app size
having switched to the Bundle.
So how is this achieved?
Let's take a look back,
and remind ourselves
what the App Bundle is.
So in essence, the App Bundle
is a new publishing format
that replaces the
traditional monolithic APK.
But the App Bundle is
not installed directly.
Instead, Play generates APKs
optimized for specific devices
from the single Bundle upload.
These APKs are much smaller than
if the developer were to deploy
a single APK for everyone.
But the single upload provides
a much simpler developer
experience than
uploading multiple APKs.
So how does this work?
So the smaller download
size is achieved
by delivering only the
resources from the app
that the specific devices need.
Deploying a single
APK would result
in all languages, densities,
and native architectures
being delivered for
all the devices.
But as we see here,
with the App Bundle,
only the relevant
languages, densities,
and native architectures
are delivered,
yielding a smaller install
on the device and a faster
download.
So on average, the App
Bundle yields a 20% reduction
in app size.
This leads to faster
downloads, which
leads to an 11% increase
in install successes,
because there are fewer chances
for the download to fail.
And, since less
disk space is used,
it also leads to a
reduction in uninstalls.
So since launch,
more than 80,000 apps
have moved over
to the App Bundle.
Those apps are now
publishing a single bundle,
and relying on Play to
deliver smaller APKs
to specific devices
tailored for them.
YAFIT BECHER: But this
is just the beginning.
The introduction
of the App Bundle
opens the door for new and
exciting delivery features
that simply wouldn't have
been possible before.
With the App
Bundle, we can build
towards a vision of
tailored delivery
that optimizes all aspects
of your app serving--
from which part of the app
to serve, to whom and when.
In order to take the App
Bundle to the next level,
we are giving you
greater control.
And that's why our
main topic, today,
is customizable delivery, which
puts you in control over how
your app is being delivered.
This will allow us
to fully realize
the potential of the App
Bundle, as it's you who
knows your app and users best.
Today, we'll cover
four new product
offerings that
demonstrate the concept
of customizable delivery.
In-app updates, that lets
you target updates directly
from your app.
Condition delivery, that
lets you choose which feature
modules to deliver
to which devices.
On-demand delivery, that
allows you to call for
features only when
you need them.
And asset delivery
for games, that
expands the App Bundle to
include game content, letting
you package your game assets
alongside your game binary,
and publish a single
artifact to Play.
We'll also talk about
internal app sharing,
that gives you an
easy way to share
test builds with your testers.
Over to Martin, to talk
about in-app updates,
our first product
offering for today.
MARTIN CHURCHILL: Thanks, Yafit.
So auto updates are really
great for seamlessly
keeping your users up to date,
but not all users receive them.
Some are never on Wi-Fi.
Others may simply have
auto updates turned off.
So some users end up using
old versions of the app.
Now, this isn't
great for developers.
For one thing, there
may be a critical bug
fix that you really need to
get out to all your users,
a new and strategic
feature you're rolling out,
a multiplayer game
where you need
to have all of your players on
the same version of the app,
or perhaps you're simply looking
to ditch support for very
old versions of the app.
Now, in-app updates, which
we're launching today,
gives you a way to trigger
updates of your app
directly from your app.
It gives you control over
the right contextual moment
to start an update, while
keeping the user in the app
and not risking
additional friction.
So in-app updates
come in two flavors--
an immediate flow that
triggers the update right away,
requiring minimal integration.
This is because Play
handles the user experience
during the update.
And a flexible
flow that lets you
customize the user
experience during the update.
This requires more
thinking and design work,
but is ultimately much
more customizable.
So let's take a look at both
of these flavors in action.
So first, we'll take a look
at the immediate in-app update
flow, with our sample
recipe finder app.
So as we can see here, the
app triggers an update,
and the user is kept
in a managed flow
until the update finishes.
So first, the user confirms that
they want to take the update,
and the download size
is revealed to the user.
Then the update is
downloaded, during which
Play manages the user
experience as we see here.
Once the update is downloaded
and ready for install,
it is applied and
control is returned
to the new, up-to-date,
shiny version of the app,
and the user can continue
their journey inside the app.
Now here, the
developer doesn't need
to do anything beyond
the initial trigger
of the update, which can happen
when the developer chooses.
Now, some developers will want
more customizability than this.
So here, we have Swiggy.
Swiggy is a food delivery
app popular in India,
with more than 10
million downloads.
Now, many of their users
aren't regularly on Wi-Fi,
and so can't benefit
from auto updates.
But by using in-app
updates, they
can prompt the user to update
while they're in the app,
and they have the
user's attention.
So as we see here, Swiggy have
incorporated a small alert icon
that notifies the user that
the update is available.
Then, when the
user investigates,
they're prompted
with an opportunity
to do an in-app update.
Once again, Play
seeks confirmation
by displaying the download size.
But for this flow, once
the user has accepted,
control is returned
immediately back to the app,
and the user can continue to
use the app while the update is
being downloaded.
Finally, when the
update is ready,
Play will inform the
app again, and the app
can do something appropriate.
For example, here,
Swiggy raises a snack bar
which provides the
opportunity for the user
to complete the update
by restarting the app--
again, into the new,
shiny version of the app.
So the flexible
in-app update flow
provides the developer
the opportunity
to customize the experience
during the in-app update.
So next, let's take a look
how this looks like in code.
So first, we acquire an
instance of an appUpdateManager
from the Play Core library.
This is an object that lets you
interact with the in-app update
API.
We make a call to find out
whether an update is available.
If it is, then we can act
appropriately-- perhaps
triggering the in-app
update flow immediately,
or perhaps rendering some button
that will do so once clicked.
Now, the Java Play Core API for
in-app updates that we see here
is available for any app to
use today in Play Core 1.5.
But in the future, we'll be
adding extension libraries
for integration with
Kotlin and Jetpack,
leading to even simpler code.
And if you're interested
in seeing that,
there was a live demo in
the developer keynote.
So that's in-app updates.
YAFIT BECHER: Thank you, Martin.
Now let's talk about how to
adjust the way your app is
installed in the first place.
Traditionally, all your
code and app contents
are always serve to all users.
But sometimes, you
have features that
are simply not applicable
to some of the users
or some of the devices.
So by including them, your
users get part of your app
that they will never use.
This is obviously not ideal.
Conditional delivery lets you
control which part of your app
would be served to which users.
With conditional
delivery, you can
set a set of conditions
under which a feature
module would be delivered, and
otherwise will be left out.
This lets you exclude a
certain part of your app
from some of the
devices, and avoid
loading your app with
irrelevant features
to the device it
is installed on,
optimizing download size
and on-device footprint
of your app.
We support three
types of conditions
for conditional delivery.
First, you can have a
module included only
for specific countries.
This is the first time
Play has let you target
part of your app this way.
Second, you can restrict a
module by minimum SDK version,
targeting only devices
above a certain version.
And third, you can
deliver your module only
to devices that support
a certain feature--
such as a VR headset.
Configuring conditional
delivery is super easy.
Once you've extracted the
feature into the module,
the only change needed is
adding installation instructions
to the Android manifest XML.
The newly-introduced
install time elements
allow you to specify
conditions for delivery.
You can include conditions for
device feature, user country,
and min SDK.
We additionally support
minimum openGL ES version.
If you leave the install
time element empty,
the module would
always be delivered.
In this example,
delivery is conditioned
by device feature and
min SDK, and the module
will be served only to n-plus
devices that have an AR camera.
The user country condition lets
you exclude or include a module
in specific
countries, and you can
specify more than one country.
Here, the module
will be deployed only
to United States and Britain.
The device country,
in this context,
is typically determined by the
user billing address attached
to the Google Play account.
As we've seen, conditions
may be combined,
and all conditions must be met
for a module to be delivered.
At runtime, you can call Play
Core API getInstalledModules
to find out which
modules are installed.
This can be used, for
example, to get access
to a certain activity contained
in a conditional module.
Once the app is installed,
conditional modules
can also be requested
through code--
even if conditions
weren't originally met.
This is useful,
for example, when
you want a specific
module to be served only
to some of the users by default,
while still letting other users
get it upon request.
Martin will talk next
on how such features can
be called for on demand.
MARTIN CHURCHILL: Thanks.
So that's modules that are
conditional at install time.
But sometimes, at
install time, you simply
do not know whether a module
is relevant for a user.
Perhaps this depends on
your individual knowledge
of the user, or their behavior
inside the app after install.
So what can you do then?
On-demand feature modules can
be used to install and remove
modules during the
lifetime of an app,
based on user behavior inside
the app, triggered via code.
For example, this might be
useful for user-driven uploads
in a consumption
app, which might only
be used by a subset of
the most engaged users.
Other use cases might
be an onboarding flow
or a customer support flow that
are rarely used more than once.
So let's explore a case study--
Netflix.
So Netflix's
customer support flow
is a feature used only by a
small subset of their users,
and is rarely used more than
once by an individual user.
But it is a fairly big component
of the app, at a few megabytes.
So it's a perfect use
case for a feature
module delivered on demand.
When the user clicks on the
customer support option,
the module is downloaded
and installed.
And once installed,
it seamlessly opens,
and the user can connect
to customer support.
This flow is live
in Netflix today.
Now, in future,
Netflix will also
configure installed
modules in other ways.
For example, it can
remove the onboarding flow
once the onboarding
flow is completed.
So how might that look?
So let's take a look
at the code, here.
So let's consider
how removing a module
would look in code like this.
So first, the
module is configured
as an unconditional
install time module.
So this is a dynamic
feature that's
extracted and separate
from the rest of the app,
but it's installed for everyone
when the app is installed.
But by keeping it separate,
when the time is right,
it can be removed in code via
the splitInstall API in Play
Core.
The Play Store will then
mark the module for removal,
and remove it before too long,
saving precious disk space.
Now, on-demand and
conditional modules
are in general
availability today,
and can be used in any app.
YAFIT BECHER: So we talked
a lot about customizing
delivery of feature modules.
But the reality is that many
times, the bulk of the content
is actually coming from
assets and that code.
This is especially true for
games, which sometimes require
massive content download to even
get the user started playing.
We know that many of you are
using CDN solutions to host
and deliver your content from.
But this results in a
suboptimal user experience.
Users install and open the game,
ready to start playing, just
to be faced with a long
progress bar waiting
for additional resources
to be downloaded.
Furthermore, since the CDN
is blind to the device asking
for the content, it
cannot optimize delivery
to the requesting client.
So you end up serving
all assets to all users,
regardless if they
will ever use them.
Another major downside
of using a CDN
is that you can't rely on
auto updates of assets.
So again, this results
in additional long waits
for updating resources after
the game is already installed.
To make asset delivery
seamless, we'll
be releasing a new set of
delivery options suited
for games.
With that, we are extending
the App Bundle format
to include game
assets, introducing
a whole new delivery construct--
the asset pack.
Unlike feature
modules, asset packs
are composed of assets only,
with no executable code,
and can be very large.
Asset packs will be
packaged in the App Bundle
alongside your
game binary, so you
can publish a single
artifact to Play containing
everything your game needs.
You can also rely
on Play to take
care of keeping your
assets up-to-date,
just like it currently
does with your game binary.
And, similarly to
the flexibility
you have with
feature modules, you
will be able to customize asset
delivery according to your game
needs.
To start, you can use this
to serve your assets upfront,
as part of the initial
install, instead
of using APK extension files.
Asset packs served
this way won't
require to publish an
additional artifact to Play,
and unlike extension
files, are not
prone to accidental deletion
by the user or other apps.
Your assets can
be easily accessed
like any assets package
in the base APK,
using Android Assets Manager.
You can sign up today
for our early access
program at this
link, and will soon
be able to include up to one
gigabyte of your game assets
in the App Bundle, avoiding
the additional complexity
of using APK extension files.
[APPLAUSE]
But again, this is
just the first step.
Stay tuned for further
announcements later this year
about additional
delivery options,
which will give you even
greater flexibility and control,
and allow larger
asset packs and enable
optimized device targeting, so
that for game assets as well,
your users will
get only the assets
suitable for their device.
So let's recap the features
we've discussed so far, today.
You can trigger updates
directly from your app,
without having your
users go to the store.
You can condition the
delivery of feature modules.
And you can call for
features on demand.
And soon, you'll be
able to package up
to one gigabyte of your game
assets in the App Bundle
and serve it as part of
the game installation.
But a lot of what
we touched on today
relies on having your app
broken up into modules.
So to fully benefit
from all this greatness,
you should consider
modularizing your app.
Let's thank Martin, and have
Ben from our developer relations
team get a little deeper
on app modularization.
We'll then talk about
our last product
announcement for today--
internal app sharing.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN WEISS: Thanks, Yafit.
Wow.
That's a lot of new ways to
ship your app to your users.
But like Yafit just said, in
order to make the most of it,
your app has to be modularized.
Traditionally, an app was
served to a user's device
as a single monolithic APK.
That contained all the
code and resources,
and all the features
to run all of your app.
With the Android
App Bundle, that
uses a split APK functionality
introduced in Android Lollipop,
makes use of this so we can
make use of all the features
that we have seen today.
Instead of packaging everything
into one single monolithic APK,
multiple configuration
APKs are being built.
Then, some of them--
suiting the user's devices
and preferences--
will be installed
onto the user's device.
This already saves your
user precious data.
You can achieve this by
simply building your Android
app as an App Bundle, and
releasing it on the Play Store.
So far, no changes to
your code are required,
but this already will lead
to decreased installation
size and faster downloads.
But I'm here to talk
about modularization.
So let's take a look at
what we did with an app--
that we made our sample
app for modularized apps.
We've gone through a
process with Plaid.
It's an app that we've used
to showcase a lot of features
throughout the years.
We used it for material design,
to animations and transitions,
and most recently dark mode.
Also, throughout
the past year, we
added major changes to the
app and modularized it,
and added dependency
injection using Dagger.
The app consists of a
home feed that displays
gathered information.
It also has a search
functionality, an about screen,
and several news sources that
can be turned on and off.
In the end, these
user-facing features
will be our feature module.
But before we
started modularizing,
we switched over to App Bundles.
This allowed us to save a
staggering 2/3 of the storage
on some user's devices.
We ship a native
library, and by only
having to ship the library
for the CPU architecture
that it's installed on, we
save a lot of data already.
From there, we were
able to make changes
to the structure Plaid has.
Usually your app consists
of multiple things that
tie in together--
of code, resources, extra
dependencies, and drawables.
After modularizing, the compiler
will enforce clean boundaries
between your feature modules
through a directed dependency
graph.
So let's take a look how
we did that within Plaid.
No matter how you
structure your code
overall within the app, no
matter which architecture
you choose, you break that
down into feature modules
beforehand.
Before we actually started
making feature modules,
we put everything into
packages per feature.
This allowed for a clean
separation of concerns already.
During that, we
started untangling
unwanted dependencies,
and in the end,
none of the feature
modules should import code
from another feature
module directly.
Then we [INAUDIBLE]
looked at our resources.
We were particularly interested
in structuring them in a way
that we can move them
to modules later on, as
well, without problems.
So for strings, we
initially created files
with a naming convention
that reflects the feature
association.
We chose to add a
module name as a prefix.
That way, they still show up
grouped together in the IDE.
We then moved the strings
into these feature resource
files as we went along.
We also renamed
layouts, drawables,
attributes in the same way,
and then moved them along.
This left us with
shared sources,
which we moved into shared
dependency called our core
library.
The core library is bundled once
within the app space module,
and can be exposed to
dynamic feature modules.
This means the
entire application
is able to access
[INAUDIBLE] dependencies
without unnecessarily
adding to the app size.
At this point, everything still
was one monolithic module.
But since we structured
our app on a feature level,
we were able to go on and create
our real first dynamic feature
module.
We started using the
most lightweight module
with the least
shared dependencies--
our About screen.
The Android Studios
New Module dialog
takes care of creating
the basic setup.
All we have to do is enter the
module name and a package name.
Directories are being created,
and the correct dependencies
are added in the
app's Gradle file.
Then we moved all the
previously structured code
and resources in
the About feature
into a newly-created module.
For most cases, it was a
fairly lightweight process,
but some did take a little bit
more work and thinking about.
So let's talk about these.
As we're using resources
from both the About feature
as well as from
the core library,
imports came from
different R files.
They became a bit
tedious to read.
In a monolithic
application, you usually
have one single of these
files, so that's not a problem.
But if you import from
multiple packages,
you can end up with
imports like this.
We were able to resolve this
with Kotlin's import aliasing.
It's a feature that
allows you to map
an import to another name.
So instead of having to write
a fully qualified import
for apps R class, we
simply remapped it to appR.
This led to more concise
and readable code.
Differentiation is
still possible and easy,
but it's way less noisy to read.
Another thing we
had to change was
the way activities are
launched within the app.
In a monolithic app,
it's possible to pass
a class directly to
the intent explicitly.
Even activities within
a library dependency
can be explicitly launched.
The dependency is directly
accessible from within the app
space module, but a
dynamic feature module
depends on the app,
which makes its content
invisible to the app module.
This means that classes in
a dynamic feature module
are inaccessible
to the app module.
So instead of passing
the class directly,
we now pass the fully
qualified class name.
The Android framework is
able to instantiate and start
the activity as it usually did.
An app containing fragments
in a dynamic feature module
can use reflection
for instantiation.
A key to modularizing
is also having
a single point of responsibility
for actions your app can take.
So we didn't want to maintain
these [INAUDIBLE] type calls
throughout the
entirety of Plaid,
so we introduced the addressable
activity interface in the app's
core library.
Then we implemented it for
each of Plaid's activities.
When needed, these
objects can also
hold keys to [INAUDIBLE]
extras in a single place.
This allows for
centralized code that
can be invoked from any module.
Alongside with the
intentTo function,
this makes launching
the activity
straightforward and type safe.
This allows for
decoupled code that
can be invoked from any module,
as well as easy to read.
Even before making use
of on-demand delivery,
we have reaped various benefits.
Plaid's build time
dropped from three minutes
down to one minute
for a clean build.
This was achieved by using
Gradle's parallel build
feature, which
enables us to build
multiple independent
features at once.
Up to a certain
limit, separating out
more independent
features will further
decrease the build time.
Overall, we gained a
more maintainable app.
This is due to
self-contained modules
and compile time
enforcement of separation.
Also, app's footprint has
dramatically decreased.
This results in
faster app downloads,
and saves precious
storage on device.
So looking back at our
tracks that we took so far,
we first identified
the features of the app
that we wanted to modularize.
In our case, those were
the user-facing features
that the app already had.
Then we started moving
the code and resources
to match the structure.
Afterwards, we created a feature
module and populated that.
Our modularized
architecture will allow us
in the future to
dynamically install modules
as we need them.
This works by depending
on the Play Core library,
and making use of
its functionality.
We can request dynamic feature
modules as they are needed,
and start installing them.
Also, if users disable
features for a longer time,
we can easily uninstall them
if they're no longer needed.
For more details
on how to do that,
check out the sample app, as
well as the Play Core library
documentation.
You can follow Plaid's
development on GitHub.
Also, check out an
article containing
more in-depth information on
the modularization process.
Thank you very much.
With that, back to you, Yafit.
[APPLAUSE]
YAFIT BECHER: Thank you.
Now, let's talk
about testing a bit.
Since we launched
the App Bundle,
we kept hearing from
developers how great it is.
But there's one thing we heard
from you loud and clear--
testing of the App
Bundle is hard.
This is especially true early
in the development lifecycle,
where you simply want
to share a test build
with your internal testers.
In the APK world, it used
to be very easy to do.
You simply sent the
APK, and the platform
knows what to do with it.
But App Bundles are
not installable.
And with Play tailoring the
served app to each device,
you want a guaranteed way to
get exactly the same binary
as your users would get.
You have asked, and
we have heard you.
Internal app sharing,
launched today,
gives you a quick and easy
way to internally share
App Bundles for testing.
All you need to do
is upload a Bundle
to Play, get a
shareable URL, and have
your testers use that URL to
download and test the app.
This is how it looks.
You simply drag
and drop to upload,
and share the generated
link with your testers.
With internal app
sharing, the app installed
is exactly the same as if it
would've officially published
to Play.
It even supports dynamic
delivery features,
including on-demand and
conditional delivery.
This way, you have
full confidence
that what you are testing
is the real thing,
and you can expect exactly the
same behavior as your users
out in the wild.
You are probably curious to
hear more about how it works,
so let's have Serge, who led
the development of internal app
sharing, dive into
the details a bit.
[APPLAUSE]
SERGE BEAUCHAMP: Thanks, Yafit.
Hello.
First, I'd like to clarify
that internal app sharing is
fundamentally different than
our existing testing programs.
Simply put, it's
not a release track.
With internal app sharing, the
test versions uploaded to Play
are served and hosted
by Play independently.
They're not part of a release
published in Play Console.
So let's touch on a
few important features.
First, uploaders don't need
to be Play Console members.
So you can authorize users
that don't have access
to the Play Store.
Test versions are re-signed by
Play with a test certificate,
so uploaders don't need access
to the production or upload
key of your app.
Play doesn't require
unique version codes,
so multiple uploaders can use
this feature independently,
and they don't have
to pick unique version
codes when they upload.
Debuggable artifacts
can also be uploaded,
so you can debug the APKs
once they're installed
on the testers' devices.
To authorize testers, you
can go to the Play Console
and choose to either
allow anyone with the link
to download and install
APKs, or to allow only users
in a predefined list.
In both cases, there's a
user cap enforced by Play.
So let me show you how
it works in practice.
Can we switch to
the laptop, please?
Can we see the lap--
yes.
Excellent.
So I have an App Bundle,
here, on my desktop.
I just did a fix for a
bug that was reported,
and I want to quickly
share it with my Q engineer
for validation.
Obviously, because
it's an App Bundle,
my tester cannot simply
install it on the device.
So what I will do is I will load
the new internal app sharing
upload page, and I will drag and
drop the bundle onto that page.
Again, here, I don't have to
worry about version codes,
because I'm
guaranteed they won't
conflict with the artifact
published in release tracks.
It shows a dialogue, and
it shows the version name
of my App Bundle that is
extracted from the Android
manifest file.
I can choose to change
the version name,
so my tester knows what
this test version is about.
Here, again, my
uploader account doesn't
need to have access
to the Play Console.
It just needs to be
authorized by the Play Console
admin for that app.
Now that the upload
has completed,
it shows a shareable link.
So I can copy that link, and
I can send it to my tester.
Can we switch to
the device, please?
Amazing.
So I have my testers
device, here.
And within a few seconds,
I should get the email.
So my tester opens the
link, and installs the app.
So there it is.
Super simple and quick.
[APPLAUSE]
This is a version of
Gmail that I built,
and I changed it so that
there's a dynamic feature module
for the Compose activity.
When I tap on the
Plus button, here, it
loads a feature module,
and it's installed by Play.
It works right away, because
the app is installed by Play.
But even better, because
my Bundle is debuggable,
I can take my device and I can
connect it to Android Studio.
I can attach the
debugger to that process,
and I can step through
the dynamic delivery code.
So that's super useful.
Can you-- oh, sorry.
Can we switch to the--
can we switch to
both devices, please?
All right.
Let me do that again.
I can step through the
dynamic delivery code.
More than that, we also built
an API endpoint, and a Play
Publisher API, so you can
automate publishing artifacts
to internal app sharing.
And you can integrate it
with third-party tools,
so you can even, for
instance, invoke it directly
from Android Studio.
So this is Play
internal app sharing.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
YAFIT BECHER: Thank you, Serge.
So just in case you've missed
it, using internal app sharing,
Serge was able to locally
debug dynamic delivery
of an on-demand feature.
Isn't that cool?
We hope that this presentation
demonstrated our commitment
to the App Bundle, and
that we are doubling down
on our vision of customized,
dynamic delivery.
In-app updates, conditional
delivery, dynamic delivery,
and internal sharing
are all live,
with documentation available,
at developer.android.com.
If you are interested in trying
out upfront asset delivery,
join our early
program at the link.
We'll have more to
share later this year,
so come and see us at events
like the Android Developer
Summit and Google Play Time.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]